over the last few days Democratic
presidential candidate Pete Budaj
was involved in some really strange
exchanges and most of them have to do
with money in politics campaign finance
a transparency and it does not look good
for mayor Pete the first one is at a
press conference before or after an
event and he's asked about why won't you
open up fundraisers to the press
he's very Curt and he says he doesn't
have a timeline for when he's going to
consider doing that he's then asked to
follow up well you're the candidate
can't you just tell your campaign to
open them up to the press and mayor Pete
says yes but there are considerations
and then he's asked as another follow up
what are the considerations and he says
I'm not going to tell you take a look at
this
is this a strategy of some kind because
it comes off looking absolutely terrible
doing close to the press events I don't
actually think is problematic in
principle it's actually a good thing for
elected officials and candidates to be
able to talk to voters privately without
the press there I think that that's
generally speaking a good thing but in
some instances but when it's big money
fundraisers and there's already
slipperiness coming from Pete about
campaign finance and then this is how he
answers the questions it doesn't look
good
here's another video where a student
activist named Greg Chung asks Buddha
judge when we talk about getting money
out of politics shouldn't that include
not taking money from million from
billionaires and doing closed-door
fundraisers and Pete just says no that's
not what getting money out of politics
should include I know the audio is not
great on this one
the video is subtitled apologies for
people who are just listening I know
that it may be hard to understand
everything that's said
I saw comments about this saying oh this
is totally tone deaf it's not that it's
tone deaf it's that this is Pete Buddha
judge telling us what he really believes
he doesn't want to stop billionaire
donations or private fund raisers
because he's a centrist status quo guy
period the bar for transparency
particularly on this issue of money and
politics has definitely changed in the
last few years with more and more
candidates saying they won't accept
corporate PAC money or money from
corporations at all or whatever Pete
Budaj
and Joe Biden are just behind on this
they are completely out of touch with
what is expected now on the progressive
left what I do think is good is that in
the same way that Joe Biden isn't
pretending to be a super progressive
he's running as a centrist and he is a
centrist Pete buddy judge is doing the
same thing although to a lesser degree
yes Pete is being slippery on Medicare
for all
with this Medicare for all who wanted
thing but on lots of these issues I'm
glad that Biden is just telling it to us
like it is and Pete is telling it to us
like it is in their policy I disagree
with them I am well to their left but
one of the things that's really good is
with some candidates you get this sense
that they're not really telling us what
they actually believe this was asserted
about Hillary Clinton in 2016 that
everything was just what she thought
would sound best at the time this has
been asserted with other candidates as
well with Mayor Pete and Joe Biden they
seem to be centrists their policies are
centrist policies they are telling us
that in public they're not hiding behind
it and I like it because it makes it
much easier for me to figure out both of
these guys are well to my right they are
not the people that I would consider
supporting in a primary he's being
upfront it's fine for him to say this
but we need to do away with the false
notion that Buddha judges any kind of
progressive period and he's making that
a very easy notion to do away with every
time he says something like this make
sure you're following the david pakman
show on instagram at david pakman show
increasingly a very popular place to
watch our videos and while you're there
follow me at David Pakman
we'll take a quick break and be back
with so much more right after this one
of our sponsors is privacy calm they're
giving you $5.00 when you sign up for
their completely free service at privacy
calm slash Pakman I've been using
privacy for a little over a year now
you've heard me talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone instead of actually using your
real credit card number the privacy app
and the browser plugin let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even autofill the card number with
one click and the payment is taken out
of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to twelve of these virtual
credit cards a month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them anytime you want so when
you do this it means you're not going to
be charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance I love using free trials
because I know I won't be charged when
the trial is over if I use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
identity private by not telling
companies who you are you're keeping
your bank or credit card info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want privacy also
offers a ten dollar a month plan that
gives you one percent cashback and lets
you create 36 credit cards a month and a
twenty five dollar a month plan tailored
more for small businesses where you can
create 60 card numbers a month and much
more but definitely go ahead and at
least get started with the free plan
you'll protect your financial info
companies can't charge you unexpectedly
and like I said you'll get $5 to spend
when you sign up at privacy calm /
Pakman